okay i want to have a conversation about
polling that is a careful conversation
and a sober conversation because there's
been a narrative building over the last
maybe 10 to 14 days that biden is
falling
and trump is rising and that this is
objectively a disaster for joe biden and
donald trump has actually applied the
term
plunging for geor not not for someone's
neckline who he's trying to talk to but
plunging from the standpoint of joe
biden's polling now the reality is
when we started getting these polls two
months ago that said
biden is up by 10. biden is up by 12.
biden is up by 15. i told you joe biden
is not going to win the popular vote
by 15 nor by 12 nor by 10. the polls are
going to tighten
and depending on how you look at it the
polls are tightening
joe biden is starting to campaign
in a bit of a different way as a result
as we get closer to the election and
that makes sense
donald trump tweeting as i told you
yesterday quote joe biden
is coming out of the basement earlier
than his hoped for 10 days
because his people told him he has no
choice
his poll numbers are plunging
so let's know the facts but let's also
not become overconfident as a result of
those facts
so first of all have the polling
averages tightened you can always find
one poll that will say almost whatever
you want but what about the averages
the real clear politics average was
biden plus 9.5 a couple of months ago
and it's tightened by a couple of points
to biden plus seven
okay it it's tighter we never really
expected biden to win by 10 in the
popular vote
would have been completely historic and
indeed the numbers have tightened from
biden with a nearly 10 point lead to a
seven point lead
in the 538 um a polling average
model you see that joe biden now is plus
7.7
at one point he was plus 9.6 that was
back
in early july so yes the polls have
tightened
is joe biden plunging no the answer is
no
and of course donald trump lies all the
time he lies and says coronavirus is
surging in new zealand when it's not
he says he's done a great job on the
virus when he is not he said in april 15
cases would soon be zero that didn't
happen we have six million
just because donald trump is wrong
about joe biden's polling plunging
doesn't mean
trump can't necessarily win and that's
where i want to
sort of go next it's really important
that our actions not be influenced
by these dumb narratives that are put
out there either by donald trump or
others
is po if polling is tightening you have
to vote and i have to vote
if polling is not tightening you have to
vote and i have to vote if trump
is tr is right that biden's polling is
plunging you have to vote and i have to
vote
that's the primary message here and i
know it's like a broken record at this
point but you're only going to have to
deal with it for two two more months
which are arguably going to be long
months but it's only two more months and
as a reminder
if you go back to september 1st of 2016
and look at the polling
between hillary clinton and donald trump
september 1
2016 four mo four years ago today
hillary clinton was plus 4.9 and of
course
we know she ultimately lost the
electoral college
is biden's lead bigger as of today yes
it's almost three points bigger than
hillary's four years ago
but so what why take a chance because
there are things going on this year that
are not in the polls
in other words voter purges are not
part of biden's seven point lead right
now planned voter suppression
is not part of the seven point lead joe
biden has right now
messing with vote by mail and the post
office and everything we've been talking
about for the last six weeks
that is not in the polls right now voter
intimidation
at the polls this vague idea that there
might be someone who knows a militia
troops
who knows what at the polls intimidating
voters that's not
in the polls so let's act as if
remember your vote could decide the
outcome
of your state individually it's unlikely
any of our
one votes will do that but collectively
if we all thought our vote didn't matter
and stayed home we actually would be
influencing the results of the states so
that's the correct approach there's no
downside
joe biden's polling is not plunging it's
tightening as expected
we've got about eight weeks to go and
this is the time
let me know where you are on the polling
i'm on twitter
deepakman and remember that you can get
the daily
audio podcast every single day
on whichever is your preferred
podcasting platform
itunes stitcher google play
spotify pandora podbean
etc there's a lot of them uh we'll see
you in just a couple of minutes
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video